[Music]
my god taking welcome back to the genjou
lien podcast so scared okay no we're
winding up for thank God anyway welcome
to the gin julep at cast where we scare
each other with thanks here yeah and I
camera out on the line hi yeah I'm
putting it down please
get you life together don't mind and
then and marry together
and it's only together because you know
what I don't really have to drive
anywhere because lick does it for me
this to me when driving Cardenas relies
on the engines but roll guys you can
start driving from the for now and you
can earn a lot of money real fast and up
to $100 a week with tips ceiling
ride-sharing service that gets you tips
and you can cash out instantly it's
amazing go to list calm ly ft.com /
Gemma Julian and get a new $500 cyber
donuts and when you're finished and
you're tired and you want to have a
drink go to wink wink will deliver wine
right to your front door and they will
do all the hard decisions for you they
will find the best wine that will fit
your palate not anyone elses palate your
palate take a little wine taste
preference quiz and then they take that
information and give you wine that's
perfect for you I now go to try wink
that's TR y wi mc.com / annejulien
save 20 bucks off your first order and
complimentary shipping Thank You sponsor
saucer
it is a pizza party Wow Julian is in a
mode and in a mode we decided that we're
gonna have a pizza party today we're
having a pizza party I was like well the
last time you had a pizza party I got I
don't know I don't know either I got
maybe your birthday like two or three
years ago yeah probably right order dot
like giant pizza that like takes up the
whole table from big moment Papa's
yeah yeah yeah how many slices is that
it's like a hundred or something not a
hundred but it's it's like a meter and a
half yeah by a meter like trick of our
whole table I hope you I know and I got
like chaff cheese and half pepperoni or
something and I was like this should be
enough for everyone right and you're
like I don't know and like maybe a
quarter it got me I know we always do
that we always over-prepare
forget like in Tehran people over we get
so much food injuring and if I were it's
like a little obscene that's my fault
though because I have that too much Jean
but I'm also like terrified of we have
people over in the manatee fat yeah the
firt from the first time I [ __ ] hung
out with you you were the host of all
hosts like yeah me no you actually
weren't like you were so concerned about
people who you barely even knew rang out
or fed and had drinks and make sure the
day all right
no I think tell me a really important
lesson and that is if you're hungry hang
out with Jenna I will make sure you get
fed and if we've been hanging out for a
long time I know you hungry and you go
need to get fish each other you said so
much when we say anything I just want to
feed you yeah you find the feet I like
getting fed you're fun to watch that I
love you I don't know I forgot I was
going to I love you but we have in a
pizza party okay so what's the spread
here
well in all fairness we did eat a little
bit when I mean as you can see terrain
was so hungry as you can see Marty so it
is about half eaten and they only
downside that anything that's happening
right now is the fact that this is not
super hot pizza you know there's a fan
blowing - so it's blowing piece of smell
into our face feels amazing mmm where'd
you get this from pizza cookery yeah if
it's cookery can you lift up your thing
yeah shake a pizza box effect
mine is yeah I do not do that okay my oh
my god oh my god I didn't do anything
what is that once a week yeah and
usually a try link calm sorry I really
am sorry I don't mean to do those them
they just kind of happened you can even
hear everything okay it's not like
clunky for you this was kinda wrinkly
like chunk Lisa is mean oh my god it's
Lenny right
to the pizza and the pizzas the
important thing here let's just really
not lose focus here okay hey okay what I
was saying is my pizza is lukewarm it's
not cold I would not [ __ ] eat it if
it was called I refuse Helvetia and I
think maybe we should start eating pizza
while we debate that oh my god
I'm putting a pound of red pepper on
this piece right up well I'll see you
want to talk about that oh you weren't
kidding blast boom this is vegan
gluten-free my questions are gluten-free
yours oh um pizza it has vegan salsa on
site oh my god vegan cheese vegan
sausage vegan pepperoni that's why I
like this because a lot of times you can
find the vegan cheese at a pizza place
but you can't find a definite not vegan
pepperoni I've never seen it except the
future so please the only place I know
of that has it and it's dank but I use
all your heart cheese mm-hmm it's like
that day of cheese - I do that can you
hear yeah I mean don't get me wrong I
love deya cheese because of Siegen
cheese and everybody likes cheese and
that's what we got that's what we got at
vegan but I follow your heart on pizza
is really nice level yeah those mio goes
what is that sorry
someone put a lot of pepper on my pizza
Tom Yoko Julie it's the big ball-peen
the plastic with the blue on it you get
it alters but it's like really mushy you
have to really handle it delicately I
Linden see India not v-mon so it's very
hard to handle so that's why a lot of
when you put it on pizza it's best
melted on pizza yeah because it's like
almost kind of gooey if you don't melt
it but you know it's just one of those
things you know fine is like I was
reading about how addictive cheese is
really yeah cheese's like straight-up
addictive like there are chemicals and
things going on in cheese like cow
cheese that gets human brains addicted
to it I never heard of that before yeah
it's [ __ ] crazy you should look there
the other so like the one bag what like
what is it I mean I can look it up right
now but I mean I just have some of that
diet [ __ ] oh my god oh my god
move your pin Miguel on the dinky Thank
You girls so we forgot to explain what
we're doing well I guess you sort of did
but we're gonna have a pizza party we're
going to chill and we're going to play
some pizza party games because Julian's
going away this weekend for last-minute
trip so we want to until I came out in
Spencer I'm Dan we've been doing our
best this week to just like alright boy
does your fault you know
because we've been hanging out this week
and having so much fun and we won the
podcast but we also wanted to like bring
the fun into the podcast and have fun
yet they're gonna get it cuz you're my
person Oh gross podcast guys yeah I'm
trying to find well okay I'm not very
curious yeah because as a vegan it's
almost been like three years for me I
think but most people say you know when
they go vegan or they give up dairy like
cheese is always really hard because
it's delicious everyone likes it you
know yeah but that's interesting that
it's cheese and not like milk or you
know yeah casomorphins I think that's
what they're called protein fragments
derived from the digestion of the milk
protein casein the distinguishing
characteristics of casomorphins is that
they have an opioid effect yes just like
you know like I'll be adjourned
obviously not as intense whatever you're
not know there's been like a lot of
headlines I think in the subject that
are like cheeses they edit crack see if
they're missing yeah so it's like
there's a lot of like clickbait but at
the end of it I think what they're
saying is the way that the casein breaks
down or is broken down rather by the
stomach the stomach it acts the case of
morph in acts as a histamine release
which is also why many people are
allergic to dairy products so it has is
dairy it's not just cheese yeah I think
I think there's something specific about
cheese I really am NOT you know burst on
it I just glazed Anarkali O'Day read it
and I was like wow that's interesting
because I know like a lot of vegans will
talk about like nothing you know most
most vegans are like yes I like I like
being a vegan that's it
a lot people are on the sense they're
like
can't give up cheese yeah so I just said
yeah and so let's eat
and so I think I read one thing on the
vegan subreddit which is actually really
cool separate some was like I think you
just have to really kind of give up this
idea of cow cheese at least oh right now
like we're sciences and whatever that
and just appreciate what cheese is
because it is I mean there's a ton of
really good vegan cheese yeah and it's
never going to taste exactly like cow
cheese at least right now it's important
to like lower that expectation to that's
crazy though yeah come on I you see
cheese like that was my [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah
Jesus yeah well let's talk about pizza
Sam for for a second so some general
pizza questions for you I actually don't
wholeheartedly know the answers to these
are you a person that likes to fold your
slice of pizza in half or now I'm a
folder
I like folding too but only if the slice
is big enough I'm not like about this
little slice life folded in half like
maybe don't hate on the size of
gluten-free pizza in front of me all I
want is like a giant New York slice and
I can never get it anywhere Ryan um okay
my question do you ever put pepperonis
on the crust and eat them when you
finish with actual slices
no because there wouldn't be any
pepperonis just left over what if you
took half no why would I do that because
a crust with pepperoni on top is better
than a cross with a pepperoni on top
well yeah no here's a real pizza
question are you the kind of person but
if the crust or not are you kidding me
people believe it cross over a creek do
not do that to me
do you know what it creating is people
who leave their crust over no okay for
real do you know the cream is yeah what
is it I'm not gonna talk about creams or
talk about pizza oh I'm fresh green is
like a monster right no yeah Oh correct
me if I'm wrong in the comments because
this I did not anticipate this coming up
in conversation I might not be too
well-versed in it but I'm pretty sure if
I forget where it was like a pine some
[ __ ] mountain somewhere in
Switzerland Sweden something like that
people weren't getting enough iodine in
their diet
and it was causing a disease called
cretinism and it had people have these
like short barreled necks and like the
other creatures know their people but
they got turned into creatures oh
there's no like mythology going on here
Julie and they're people with a disorder
so that's why they start putting iodine
and things like your table salt so that
they make sure that people don't just
get cretinism can we confirm that in the
comments yeah that could be a tall tale
sounds like really oh I know I believe
you why are you quitting the on creamy
cuz you said you you said people that
what but leave their crusts are cretins
and I'm like hey man that's that's a
[ __ ] real thing so you're saying that
was a derogatory term that yeah I
apologize if anyone watches the podcast
and is cream to all my [ __ ] days I
apologize and it doesn't happen very
often anymore Bob it's just amended was
getting iodine in United okay but having
your grandpa and it's still a you know
sensitive subject I'm sorry about your
cream grandpa
oh my god I'm serious oh I just really
get it I'm sorry
thousand faces oh my god you're a
monster if you leave the crust over and
I don't want you at my party because
those crusts ninety-nine percent of time
I can't eat and I wish I could because
they're the best
you think the crust is the best no I
didn't sit into that then why wouldn't
you just eat bread because because the
cross played an integral part in making
that pizza happen and they just let get
left behind are you kidding are you
kidding I like guys like NASA leaving
behind all the scientists who's launched
well I guess they do do that I mean like
the crust pulls everything together okay
it's an MEP and they're all often
disregarded so know that we eat vegan
blue cheese there's a place that we
order it from India also makes one in a
jar whatever bottle rather um but when I
used to eat like regular blue cheese the
cross was like my favorite part it's so
easy to dip in the blue cheese which I
think like a service right shape was
yeah but I used to never eat blue cheese
with my pizza
until like late high school my friend
would always get blue cheese I'm like
girl you nasty
okay and you need Jesus that is not
right and then I tried it and it was
like holy Yahoo cheese is your like
favorite anymore um but I used to do
that a lot it's not as good with the D
in blue cheese because it's the in blue
cheese it's not as good so sometimes I
will leave the crust because like I'd
rather have pizza than bread yeah I'm in
order a hot bread for dinner you know
what you could do with the crust is you
can just maybe stop complaining about it
because you can have the pizza and then
you have crust afterwards so it's like a
little bit of both what you get a pizza
with the sauce and the cheese and the
pound of pepper and when you're done
with that maybe you don't want more of
the exact same things so you have some
nice refreshing crisp bread that's oh
it's attached to the pizza it's right
here for you mmm God doing I just think
crusts are often undervalued so I don't
like it why why don't I like your why
are they undervalue yeah why do you
think it's undervalued I think people
use the crust as a handle to eat our
pizza and then they're like fine and
then that's it and then there's just
like I hate seeing empty pizza boxes
with like five crusts that does mean yes
I think Rome does that
oh that direct call out though no okay I
see where you're coming from though
because if I see someone's pizza box and
it's just below cross it's sort of like
yeah I'm great you're ungrateful for all
that a little in brief but but I would
never leave all the crusts I'd leave
like muddy white boxes with an entire
pieces worth of cross that most people's
parents cut the crust off their bread
and yeah I was out there apples yeah you
caught a little just kidding that's top
of your decision and you can do it you
want so I can eat with you all of that
all right another question so which type
of pizza tastes better
okay circular pizza or a square don't do
this to me don't worry because you know
how I feel I love I have to say circular
I love fresh brothers but there's
something classic about a pizza like
this where it comes in a pie you get a
slice that's a triangle shape not a
square shape mm-hmm it's almost like no
no no let's don't get it
fresh product has a circle Pizza they
cut it into squares the pizza itself
isn't square oh you're right I guess so
you're saying when the pizza is like a
definite like a square or a rectangle
yeah don't even think I've ever had one
of those in my life like a sheet pizza
like a birthday party never has no I
never had to growing up okay I could use
my cuz I gonna need it yeah but that you
are 15 then you never had pizza from 0
to 15 shaped like a square from 0 to 15
everything is aboard please you don't
remember and never are two totally
different things okay
as far as I remember you write like a
school lunch maybe or you went to
someone else's birthday party and they
order a big sheet pizza or like a sheet
cake you know I'm talking about yeah no
I know what the sheet pizza is I just
have no specific memory of how that
tasted compared to normal Tito see my
cafeteria like sheet pizza was on
another level was it like good or bad it
was so bad that it was amazing it was
like plastic amazing I had cavity okay
so now that I think of it amazing but it
tasted like plastic and rubber good
plastic but really it did worse things
to your body than prosecutor but in the
same way that like you like McDonald's
you name it you know what I'm saying I
get it it's like such garbage that's
precious exactly but it works in
McDonald so then I guess I can answer
that question for you sheet pizza is
good for when you want really really
garbage of something and just enjoy it
and regular circle pizza is when you
want the actual the real thing you want
a pie a pizza oh okay hey hey I really
like some pizza you don't say I could go
for a real good sheet of Shakey's Pizza
no like you want
wellyou've a pie how about these two
things okay Pizza Hut comes in a circle
which could be considered not great
pizza and 7-eleven pizza comes in to
start see that's 7-eleven of the sheet
pizza in this situation oh yes it's a
circle but it's the sheet pizza in
essence because it's such garbage and
it's filling a glass contender on the
street corner no 7-elevens are on street
corners sometime
they're in really nice places okay
they could be inside of a street corner
beautiful subway honest to be creepy
okay sorry oh can you go from a 7-eleven
to buy cigarettes and there's pizza
there yeah I used to like eat hot dogs
from Thailand are you eight from setting
a pretty dank it's a really good it's
not the type of pizza that you say I
would like pizza it's the type of pizza
that you're like oh look there's pizza
yeah right yeah yes there I mean it's
there in the glass case they have a
little heater and it's it's like kill me
or eat me and you're like optic dog it's
pretty good I've never has been on pizza
but I get I get I mean I get the appeal
of that I just think when you're it's a
Friday night you're snuggled up with
your honey you want to watch a movie
you're like actually grabs like some
7-eleven hot warm pizza no sometimes you
just hungry you know I'm like oh yeah I
feel like you're throwing like a red
herring right now sometimes you're just
hungry yeah I know that session 11 pizza
you've never eaten food from like a gas
station and been like I'm so hungry I
really just don't care like I don't I
don't care what this is I'm just gonna
eat it no I love gas station food I see
gas station wings yeah so what's the
problem there is no problem it's just
different than bar wings and and like
pizzeria Pizza it's just different
there's two animals two different creams
Julie hi how dare you
sorry we were nervous I'm sorry oh my
god I'm genuinely so sorry so you really
think the circle pizza is better than
square pizza yes
final answer what do you think I mean it
reverses on a year I don't disagree with
you because some of my tall almost all
of my favorite pizza is shaped like a
circle
although there is place one place in
Harvard Square called Pinocchio's it has
a square pizza that is really delicious
so they can come to the circle pizza
play like I'm typically not a fan of
like Sicilian pizza you know I mean I
like whatever the other Italian pizza is
you're Politan you know what I like is
Neapolitan pizza what's that it's like
remember
hundred degrees yeah I was called yeah
where it's like like a really tangy
marinara sauce not so much cheese and I
like a nice puffy almost kind of burnt
crust I love that Molina see I feel like
there's like a some kind of like law of
diminishing returns or whatever when it
comes to pizza you know like some of
those like artisan whatever pizzas look
at it it gets past a point and then I
don't appreciate it anymore I'm like
look I get it alright you use all this
like fancy [ __ ] on here you everything's
really high-quality but like it's still
pizza to me and you could have stopped
like 20 steps before that and it would
have been just as fine just as fine up
in my opinion here's where I'll disagree
Neapolitan pizza and a word artisan I
can understand that's used in a really
douchey context a lot I get that but
what I think is like there's a very
distinctive flavor in both the sauce and
the crust of Neapolitan pizza in my
experience it's like it's unlike any
special are period pizza but I know you
know what I'm in the mood for I looking
sophisticated okay I've been in the mood
specifically for Neapolitan pizza before
and there's nothing there's no peace on
earth that would make my thirst quenched
unless it was that pizza no I'm sorry
mmm-hmm I'm sorry I don't have that I
don't have that at all I feel like I can
tell the difference between like a good
like wanting to eat meat with a good
hamburger and like a crappy hamburger I
feel like you can they can make those
really fancy or whatever and I get where
it goes past the threshold of like fancy
you know but like with pizza sometimes I
just can't tell once it's like past a
certain point of fancy it's pumpkin
pizza so not seriously like on BuzzFeed
where they taste a five dollar something
versus a 500 dollar sign do you think
they're just bullshitting when they're
eating the really expensive pizza no I
didn't say the pizza one did they do a
pizza one no I didn't see that one but
the other ones yeah I feel like a
hamburger I could tell path I could tell
something like [ __ ] if I ate sushi I
imagine there's a big difference but
pizza for me no that's a bold statement
and that's a bold stance I think because
when it comes to like not high-end but
like
different pizza not Domino's like not
your like your delivery pizzas like
pizzas that are just not better they're
just different like I'm not trying to
say that they're better they're just a
different page no it's not for me
I like cheap grubby dirty pizza because
I'm a nasty nasty decision I'm white
trash I'm relevant okay I'm here but
it's [ __ ] dominoes what you know what
pizza is trash though and I'm sorry and
I offend anybody
but [ __ ] Papa John's is hot garbage
it is not for me I'm not gonna argue
with that
not for me Papa blessed Oh probably that
is not for me my friend Reid used to
work at Top Gun he works at Papa's oh
yeah and I would go in there and like
visit him or whatever like uh he wants
to play me something with [ __ ] no I
really don't know I don't want to speak
I really really don't uh yeah he was a
delivery boy for them one time he got
robbed
oh [ __ ] that sucks is that terrifying
yeah coke I mean I heard some horror
stories about that kind of thing haven't
gone out here okay but so should we uh
swivel over to pin the tail on the dinky
oh we're doing party already oh my god
woman I'm trying to think of other piece
of questions I wanted to ask you you had
a bunch of my brain okay I have a
question Oh what would you rather hmm
stop your [ __ ] toe on the sofa four
times in a row once a month for the rest
of your life how I never have to eat
cold pizza again I love cold beer I got
my toe I would up and probably put my
toe twice that amount just so I could
never touch close pizza no I love
clothes each ah no you don't know what
woody love is called Peter that's
impossible
I love coffee so I always have since I
was a kid that is the most disgusting
thing you literally ever said to me
no no I still love Colby why and why the
cheese is like basically useless it's
cold the toppings are done they're
roasted and all right up sad no I love
it
it's really really good there are times
I feel like it tastes better cold better
does hot rap in sand no one is gonna
tell you that tomato I don't even know
you
that's so crazy it's really good this is
not this this is just one of those
things will never understand each other
ever on that topic I mean can you
understand that guys she likes to eat
cold pizza better than hot it's really
good don't no don't do that
and then sneeze and cough a bunch on the
podcast and not sneeze I did not feel be
[ __ ] nasty boy fine very fine I'm not
so much
I just I'm I feel like I didn't start
putting like extra stuff on if you
thought like I do like red pepper around
my pizzas it's good sometimes sometimes
anyone it is but I didn't like doing
that till I was like adult adult like
maybe after 25 what happens I mean I
think I was probably just drunken hungry
before that you know you're several
monday or like hey this is kind of gross
about something no I mean I didn't I was
I think I only ate like pizza I'm like a
Saturday night you know what I mean yeah
but when when I would eat pizza be like
what I'm [ __ ] drunk you know turn off
my diet be much more strict than it is
know if you know what I'm saying what is
your favorite homemade pizza that you've
ever made have you do have how many
piece of it oh yeah the one that we made
the Buffalo man nothing was bomb damn I
was I can't pin chest right yeah that
was like one of the first Pinterest
things that we've ever done it was like
it was a Halloween where we dressed
peach up as a turtle right label
homemade crust and pizza I'm gluten-free
and by the time general vegan I wasn't
so might have had regular cheesy or said
but we had the same crust and at buffalo
chickpea on top yeah it's like the you
can mother golf Pinterest
Buffalo Chip PPS are some immigrants but
even if you bought across and you just
need that it's like Buffalo
chickpeas look mashed together sort of
yes
it looks like that there's a creamy
ranch and believe me added some cashews
and stuff like that it's really really
tasty house anything my favorite pizza
I've ever made
yeah what was your favorite how many
Pizza that one's going on he's made some
pretty crazy teach us stuff so you know
you know one of my favorite pizza things
I made as of recently when Julian got
his wisdom teeth out I'm pretty sure I
saw in Shane Dawson's video burn that
pizza in a mug and it seems so
ridiculous again you can look it up on
Pinterest there's all kinds of like
these microwaves with my recipes I mean
there's like five ingredients I was like
what's flour right but there's like it's
not just pizza there's like so many
there's like monkey bread and brownies
and apple pies in extreme them yeah so
you put all the ingredients together
into a mug you microwave them between
like 30 seconds in a minute depending on
what it is two minutes I don't know and
it cooks everything together so this
particular one was pizza because Julian
got his wisdom teeth out he's like man I
just really want some pizza and I was
like actually boy I got you so it's like
flour and oil and water and milk or
something in the Bob beggin Saturday
baking powder baking soda yeah and you
mix that together as the dough at the
bottom then you put a little bit of
marinara sauce on top of that Jenny
sprinkle cheese on it and you really
want to put like pepperonis or whatever
on there you whatever toppings and I
think you microwave it for a minute and
a half and then I gave it to you and I
was like I can go she enough to it's
gonna do I think it's gonna be that
sounds messy like mushy like dough like
cook you eat it with a spoon I would say
that has a tape that is so [ __ ] like
stupid and ridiculous
and it is delicious I would say that has
the same delicious taste as like a
cafeteria pizza well yeah right it has a
really simple good kind of graceful like
really good yeah well I made that
marinara sauce which is why it took a
little bit extra time didn't have any we
only had
so if you have a got two minutes to make
yourself a mug pizza like I wish I knew
how to do that like in college and it's
not like a lot of calories and there's
like 200 or something if you have a
little pizza in a mug and you're like I
this was fulfilling my needs to have
pizza my deriding my phonemic quick easy
to which is less than I look 150 we put
it in a MyFitnessPal and I was shocked
and I was like Julian you want me to
make you another one like you're good
but not so I said yes and then she did
because it's probably equivalent to
having like a slice of pizza yeah you
know like a good sized slice yep yeah
but it's mushy and hot and you don't
need an oven or like anything like I
wish I knew that in college college that
was an amazing right oh yeah because you
have a microwave in your dormers you
could just make so many pizzas in mugs
and that's a great drum snack boy yeah
it's like a great John thing but um yeah
that was a really good pizza
I'll make pizza often my dad used to
make us pizza bagels for dinner every so
often which were so delicious
Jamie's anything no no you and your
pizza bagels us dude okay there is uh I
grew up in a place that was like oh we
have large Jewish populations we had a
lot of Jewish like bakeries bagel places
that kind of thing the most [ __ ]
unbelievable bit like bagel places ever
and you can go in you can get we do a
New York yeah pizza roll up see I know
it's better like pizza bagel hot dogs so
it would be a hot dog like with pizza
inside of a bagel shaped like a hot dog
they'd be like a pizza bagel you get
with cheese pepperoni like all different
kind of use so baby wrap it either
silver foil or gold foil and the cheese
is like melted to the foil and is like
oh my god [ __ ] you know what's so funny
about that black is that you probably
were in the birthplace or at least in
the US of something like that like at
creation the bagel keep the dagger ever
and I had to cheat like the shitty
ripoff at Costco as a kid and I
remembered I'm like what you're
describing is exactly they would there
was like this big Costco bagel dog or
was like a hot dog in a bagel that the
bagel the bagel on the surrounding was
like seasoned like pizza
and you would get it was huge and it was
like so delicious but I know it was the
crappy LA ripoff of what you had oh yeah
going up that's so funny because I
remember I'm reading that as a kid well
you know how much food comes out up
saying you act we got Buffalo boy you
know I have Buffalo needs because I was
like raised up on some the greatest
Buffalo that there is boy and white hot
dogs white hot I'm Benjamin of San York
I'm almost positive or they're just like
an upstate New York State they're so
good
but like I had a barbecue whatever you
know you have your hamburgers and your
hot dogs and you have red hots for my
heart
some people would usually have like on
the neighbor there are barbecues yeah
just I would get like red hots away hot
that's cozy yeah really good you know
yeah yeah yeah
did you like why not yeah really good
they just taste a little different I
forget what it is is different about
them but they're really good reaso
things like hot dogs I have just I like
hot dogs yeah we found some good game my
dogs are doc Oh eating show oh yeah yeah
the Darko's those are really good yeah
those are good I don't want to do some
opinion
I want to pin the tail on teeth oh yeah
no real pain sick [ __ ] so that escalated
so quickly so alright are we doing it no
moving the party room or later you're
gonna be surprised it's up beats up no
this is part of the pizza party we're
partying are you gonna hold it am I
going first are you I want you to put
tape on here I'm scared
so this is dink the dinky and we're
gonna play pin the tail on the dinky
but before we do I'd like to quickly
talk about our friends our buddy right
now guys you can start driving for
american-made driving the best job in
the world you pick your own hours you
work when you want take your car and you
clock in that's it
you can earn up to hundreds of dollars
per week plus tips drive for lift the
company to treat you better they are the
best ride-sharing company out there
every time I have the lift the driver is
so nice and that's something they take
pride in and that is having really nice
awesome drivers and that could be used
they're looking for new drivers only
lift offers in app tipping and you keep
100% of the tips plus Express pay lets
you cash out instantly so you don't have
to wait days or even weeks lyft has even
taken the guesswork out of pickups the
new answer vice uses color coding to
help passengers fly their drivers which
is so [ __ ] cool that you have a color
that you're looking for on your list so
if everyone can lift you know which
one's yours and vice versa if you're the
driver you can find your passengers
easily all this bug it's a simple
formula guys happy drivers need happy
customers maybe that's like 9 out of 10
lyft drivers get a perfect 5 star rating
on their rides right now you can join
the ride-sharing company that believes
in treating its people better by going
to lift ly ft y ft comm slash Jenna
Julianne and get a $500 driver new
driver bonus right and also brought to
you by wink
guys wink understands that there's
nothing better than a great glass of
wine they have given you amazing access
to great wines from around the world
that you're guaranteed to love go to try
wink that's TOI winc calm take the click
pallet profile quiz and wink will
recommend wines perfect for your palate
specifically shipped right to your door
every month none of your time is wasted
or in the store buying bottles based on
the label which I am so guilty of doing
no more time guessing which wines will
be good this time
wink takes care of all that link basis
the wines they send you on your taste
preferences wink will even introduce you
to new rare and custom lines that you
can't find anywhere else so they'll tell
you the story behind each one as well so
get into wink join for free skin
any month and cancel anytime plus Winkle
will have a hundred percent satisfaction
guarantee so you never have to pay for a
bottle you don't like right now we could
keep giving you guys 20 bucks off your
first order when you go to try wink tear
why winc calm / annejulien so even cover
the shipping for you guys try it you
won't be disappointed finicky sponsors
where were we sorry I had to think he
told me to do your [ __ ] how did you even
do that that means seeing that you hear
of them I'm good at things I'm good at
things
no I realize when you're like doing
something nice and you're like oh I'll
bring the pieces in the podcast room and
I'm like okay babe and then I come in
here like I should have known better I
should have known better you did it but
you didn't okay so how about you just
put the beanie over your eyes why can't
I wear my minion blanket over my eyes
are you just finding me in my chair
yeah why yeah so the first game at this
pizza party is pin the tail on the dinky
so take our headphones you can't really
happen that's why I want to spin around
and choke that's funny
such a funny [ __ ] okay my hand will come
through
all right kids move daddy's gonna spend
mommy yeah wait are you gonna hold the
pin here no give it to me after on
revenge
okay here we go I'm scared oh [ __ ] can
you lean your chair up a little bit yeah
here we go stick ready okay one more oh
okay I don't like here this is your this
is your it and this is a pin on top
that's okay you can sew in the tail on
the dinky it's right up here this is the
board can you finish I can do it
go deeper than what the hell I was like
really good excited coming out of this
bottle very good thanks me what how'd
you do something I don't know did you
cheat this is rigged
no I didn't cheat it's like a really
good placement I'm not gonna get in
you're like wow it's actually pretty
[ __ ] up in love oh boy I'm gonna
[ __ ] win yeah that was definitely on
his bottle teeth no he goes up there nah
it doesn't click on okay put this on let
me spin you put your legs up though it
is so disorienting like I feel like I'm
going to be sick well I like being sick
it's going in one direction is whatever
and then going the other way are to put
this on you look over your head and the
hold your arm through it so I'm going to
get a seat cause I'm gonna need you to
all right here we go pizza party baby
you have to cover your eyes and covering
us alright you ready yeah oh no see all
wrong you're a little boy you're only
halfway there daughters are being watch
this
oh this isn't worth all the food doesn't
like this oh I told you I was gonna be
sick
hey I'm actually gonna vote I told you
all right don't move Rosie
here's a pen got it yeah all right
pin the tail on the Bakey [ __ ] where is
it
oh that looks phallic that's very sour
al pinky come on they're too far
I feel long we should do a game someday
where we just center on in those chairs
and with something over your head and
like do some entering not long after
eating pizza oh okay that's only round
of doing all right yeah no there's only
time you're apparently really good at
that game which I don't know what that
means but okay I don't I don't know babe
I don't think it means anything
no no no no no no one time when I was
little I was putting pepper Julian I was
putting like black pepper on my eggs
like my scrambled eggs yeah you know how
much I like my black pepper I like on
things yeah you do
and uh my little cousin was like six or
something at the time and he looks mean
goes enough my egg that is so funny you
just like I'm sick of it
ah you're gonna hurt someone like I'm
sorry
so I'm gonna send you is my pattern no
enough okay what cane do we have next
so I found a a minute to win it game
where you SAS cups I think this show
it's not everybody as a watched minute
to win it when guy Getty was the host
it was pretty look at that you're great
it was really exciting
remember never watch it yeah we should
find it I was on Hulu Netflix I don't
know washers on YouTube I think a lot of
that member on YouTube I watch like
whole episodes you know yeah hey I was
drinking man dreamer diet [ __ ] oh my god
I saw you know the fan of Cochran as
kids no more of a diet captain oh my god
I'm sorry okay so the game on the show
is that they have 36 cups I think we
have like 21 because I read this this is
better for kids and we're basically kids
we are basically good so you have to
stack them into a pyramid and then
unpack them back like this a bus in one
minute you have a minute to win it
oh that the names hour comes from okay
yes okay so you're gonna go first to me
you're going say do I have to figure out
how to stack them on the fly
be careful you learned to stand up but
like don't worry over my toes with your
wheels boy what wait wait you can't go
ahead sir
cello fans do you have it you're like a
strategy or anything you're just gonna
go hey hey no hands off the cops
no bad otter
so I stack them and unpack remember you
stack them into a pyramid menu and sack
them do you have a strategy I've figured
hours ago
Oh Rajee okay do you have a minute to
win it
good luck up movie we go baby no it
needs to be a flat a flat pyramid flat
did yeah there you go
ten seconds is gone by - is 12 seconds
[Music]
17 all the 1924-25
Oh Julie you're killing it
alright 33 seconds so you just have to
get them down oh my god laughing yeah
how did you do that I never told you
this dad was the cup stacking champion
in my high school anyway now I
definitely love it I don't think I can
tell you when because you didn't do the
slide down the thing no I had to dumb it
down a little bit so I was not to give
it away oh oh I love how I just kind of
nailed that how many did you do across
the bottom I am not telling you [ __ ] boy
I'm gonna do it star you know if you
lose on this you don't get to say diet
[ __ ] anymore
this is a thing in the past oh yeah I'll
take it out now yeah
and don't forget we have one more party
game after this all right are you ready
you have a minute to win it starting get
your hands off the go Phoebe how many of
you do across the bottom like 13 or 14
hey boy
all right 10 seconds gone hey nice job
nice job make sure you're being careful
julienne don't be weird and 15 seconds
gone oh no I think I did it wrong I
gotta move my mind you got this
keep going oh there you go you got half
a minute to win it now oh my god no yeah
hey yes I win it because I'd like to
just say that they're definitely an
advantage in going second definitely an
advantage are you talking about nothing
is it give you about 0.4 seconds and we
sit because TV doing God am I done
all right where's the last [ __ ] party
game time seat okay we're seriously
gonna play hide and seek
oh wait really yeah how much time I have
to hide 30 seconds I don't know yeah you
learn the hadith and talk so you can't
hear what I'm doing okay but you have to
be in the charity in this room okay are
you ready
yeah it's really hard because this room
is like completely full yeah it's pretty
full how are you ready yeah check out
2:30 10:15 what are you cooking
all right ready go 1 2 3
Oh
[Music]
well are you ready
okay my dad did it too rugged okay focus
oh my god alright well you pulled that
him over there so much tire like 50
seconds Wilson oh my god I didn't I
didn't think that your ankles could done
like I didn't know you had enough dorsal
flexion to get yourself in that position
working on that dorsal flexion but thank
you
oh my god it's your turn to hide how my
sister
oh you have to go you need the blanket
over your head two and thirty Seconds go
one one thousand two one thousand I hate
me Lisa count like 1,000 between numbers
he has a Mississippi one Mississippi two
Mississippi three Mississippi
but I guess Mississippi also doesn't
doesn't help I don't know just count
maybe just have good cadence with your
words ready 1 2 3 that's good
I'm like rambling right now rambling
hard core okay and are you underneath
the green screen thank you behind the
dream screams I'm in the metaphor of God
what you got under there
let's do this so then whatever the
background is this is a nice boy it's a
big stress I'm gonna get him no I read
inner bed covered so much just happened
big thing do you want to lift up the
portal because if I found leave it
doesn't work this nail down it'll ruin
it don't don't pull that's always hiding
that's you see it's okay and just why
mr. murderface oh my god stop it
here's all right can you be careful in
the pin Oh what if I just I think you're
hiding Oh Julian birthday party just got
so fun yeah just like Stavros doesn't
afford head for fun I do weird things on
my free time Hayden said Oh cute did you
beat me in the cuffs a canary cheer up
witness the murder and call the police
stop seriously I'm never gonna believe
oh wait what is that boy I won't eat you
I got snapped you're okay are you
because I believe boy wait yeah well you
have a minute to win it
good luck no no no don't watch it
reminds me matter with you it's moving
well I share it sounds good
perfect each animal turn remember we
were podcasting and peaches outside and
as like wait that's how I teach cuz
Jenni like when I left her out front
speaker wood painted on it no she was in
here because she was in here earlier
she's fine okay but yeah it's really fun
no jewelry I hope you guys enjoyed I
definitely love this this is a great
idea it was really fun because sometimes
I just want to like have a good time
with you remember miss you and I know I
know a lot of you guys really like
last-minute trips and stuff I do too a
lot but like I do miss you and you I
know it's so it's the route it's the one
thing that like it's a it's a lot you
know it the trips are fun the episodes
are amazingly fulfilling but you know
I've never missed you like this because
when we first started doing I miss you
to go the you know I was I'm in love
with you and I was far away but yeah
it's definitely one of those things it
makes you it makes me appreciate my time
with you a lot cuz we are like super
spoiled and whenever we go somewhere one
of us can only figure out a way to go
with the other to support them I mean
recently that leads like not been able
to travel if we were together you know
yeah and the things you guys are the
best because you are part of our life
and we'd love to share these moments
with you so hopefully you guys enjoyed
this study but you had some pizza party
with our pizza Heidi yeah please if you
have if you didn't eat pizza while you
watch this pizza party make sure you do
that next time because we're doing more
pizza parties and if you have any better
games that we could do in a podcast
Ushio like hide and seek for the next
pizza party podcast lettuce
all right yeah I mean it's very fun
doing stuff on the tide can also buy
stuff like we get by pinatas and like I
want a [ __ ] pinata I want to find a
pinata champion and have them on the
podcast and show us how they beat the
[ __ ] out of the pot or a pinata
that's the thing that this young lady we
should find one or have a tournament
definitely she's are having all those
things yeah yeah thank you guys we'll
see you next week check out the sponsors
I relied and I also thank you guys for
being so supportive and understanding
last week we did have a podcast life
just kind of all around us but thank you
yeah we took a Morial day off we
received green Nicky Lee Miller wedding
live it was pretty great congratulations
to them to the price and again my name
is boo all right well no no no no no oh
my god no I'm not gonna see you sneeze
all night I am people once
just don't say support anymore and we'll
be fine please you know the word that
you almost cut out watch me press you
forgot it hey one diet comet stop
[Music]
you
[Music]